this is the theme of the show so far
people are getting [__] by the
algorithm not the way they think where
they're not getting as many views as
they think they deserve based on their
insecurity and ego they're getting
[__] by the algorithm because they're
not making content that's business smart
they're trying to make content that they
think will do well in Social or why they
want it you know the things that people
want or why they buy yes yeah make
content about that you need to think
back to the 200 300 conversations you
had and why and what they were looking
for and now you need to make videos
talking about that scale content brother
if you don't want to make the same [__]
as everyone else don't make the same
[__] as everyone else the problem is
people don't have the courage for it to
not work at
first